so um outside of
religion what else are your deal
breakers like so you have to have the
same religion as a girl
more times than not
abraham abrahamic faith okay but
more times like i will probably lean
towards uh christian and you're his
friend so does he does he only date does
he only date the christian girls i don't
know what he dates i just met trav i'm
glad i'm fortunate to meet this oh you
just met him i thought you guys knew
each other i noticed in august as a
great guy stand up guy
mind me i can't speak on him but me
personally
my deal breakers
will be people
that really don't have no driving
motivation like i said i was raised by a
single mother so i get out of the mud
so i don't want anybody that's lazy i
want ain't no one that doesn't have no
ambition like i don't care
where you are in your life at this stage
when you're speaking when you're when
we're speaking
you have to tell like if we're talking
you say what do you want to do in the
future
you have to tell me oh my plans to do
this and that are you have an idea if
you're just sitting around okay so what
else what else what else
what else yeah
but hey i'm all about connections we are
heterosexual men who are attracted to
creatures
would you guys date a girl that's
overweight
no i have a six-pack
jesus christ god please forgive me
no
active lifestyle
and
i probably attract people in that
section so
no disc but i don't think overweight
people single mom
single mom better response a better
response
hey
a better response would have been
that's just not my preference
i have a personal training certificate
i'll put her to work
i'm getting twisted
tonight
i'm sorry i have to recuperate because
you did you date a girl as a kid though
yeah this means honestly
my my oldest brother my oldest brother
he is dating a woman well it's her
fiance now they can get married
and
when i came to london for the first time
i was born in england i came back to
london for the first time he was dating
a lady and she had a child already but
the way they had the relationship
her child and then my my brother it was
just so like seamless you felt like it's
just as natural having a child doesn't
really affect me in general like if i
really love you i love your child at the
same time yes so that's not really a
deal breaker in my opinion if you have
someone that's toxic in a relationship
then it might be a factor where it goes
let's say your your ex partner with them
you don't have a good relationship with
it it might be a little techy it might
be
it might ruin our hinder things
especially
you having a child in general mm-hmm
doesn't really affect how i feel about
you and if i
if i love you and i feel like i can take
you seriously then obviously i'll play
the work i wouldn't i wouldn't you
wouldn't no no
i love kids i just
i think
like i'm out of you so you don't rate it
no i mean look at i love i really do
like i love kids like i get really
excited when i see babies because
they're like all chubby and stuff you
know
but um i don't know i just feel like
there's something special about like
having your first child like with
somebody that's someone that already
yeah yeah like together and i just don't
like it's like a bond you're supposed to
have with like one person i think but
you don't think
you can love their you can know you
don't think you can love their child and
then have your own child with them
i think i think i absolutely could but i
would just rather not like i would just
rather date someone without kids
[Music]
earlier did you not say you could have
multiple soul partners or did i make
that i was so tired so yeah oh yeah we
forgot to eat soulmates
did you say that yes no i i don't
believe in soul mates i think we choose
who we date
and i think you're who you date and
attract is based on your choices like if
i gained a hundred pounds i think my
partner would be very different then all
right so if you if you dated somebody
and you thought you loved him and then
had a child
would there would that then eliminate
you from
dating anyone else because
you've got a special tie with that
person
if i wait i had the kid
yes you had the child well i think if i
had a kid that would eliminate like a
lot of guys probably wouldn't want to
date me because i had the kid
but there's still guys that will date
yeah they would women who have children
there's good guys out there
no i know but i don't think it makes
someone a bad guy because they don't
want to date someone with kids
oh that's what he said that's what he
said
those were didn't come with mama fever
no i think
what would you say
those words didn't come up oh okay okay
okay are archer thinks different
even though we do agree on certain
things or some things this is
this is the
actual youtube thing the admin oh wait
the bot is getting on to you because you
keep on sniffing
well the reason why i keep on sniffing
is because i have a condition called
adam noise hey who's lemonade that's my
moderator yeah that's the moderator
sorry
drug
okay okay guys don't respond to the comp
please don't don't don't no no don't
talk to me i'm definitely going to
defend myself
because it kind of interrupts the yeah
i'm
it's just it says it's kind of a waste
of time to just like go back and forth
with trolls
this is not a moderator it's not it's
it's a moderator
wait so would you date a girl with a kid
personally
no okay i won't because i have a son
okay
so
it's just a bit weird to introduce my
son to somebody else and then
another child too it just makes things
are
very complicated
something that i'm just not ready for
personally
what were you saying about soul ties you
had a question earlier
i can't remember what it was um somebody
in the comments
because i'm in the comments you guys see
me commenting and everything yeah
if you if you remember what i was trying
to say then
hit me hit up the comments
and i'll definitely read it because my
phone's underneath the table so yeah
do you guys believe in soul ties
like basically every person you like
sleep with you have like a connection
with them sort of for the rest of your
life i would like to chime in first
really quick and just make it get
straight to the point yes yeah i believe
one person
out of that two-person party if it's a
two-person thing
somebody would get more attached to the
other
and it would bring that tie i believe
obviously sex created by god for the
reason of procreation and within
marriage
for
um intimacy and pleasure
that being
said uh yes i do believe it's all ties
stop stop stop
sorry i'm one for the comments
i'm in the comments if you guys want to
say anything i'll clap back
you just have to ignore the like
comments
yeah